i've fought in the ring and i do have
hot blood
um but it's usually hot blood when it
deals
with people being bullied i don't have a
problem power
i have a huge problem with abuse of
power
[Applause]
trained in muay thai and with an
impressive 7-1 record in mixed martial
arts competition
gina carano is seen as the face of
women's mma paving the way for fighters
like ronda rousey
and amanda nunes in 2009 she left
professional fighting but the reputation
she carved out
led to hollywood action stardom from her
front and center role in the knockdown
dragon thriller haywire
was superhuman with incredible strength
and invincibility in deadpool
and most notably as crowd favorite cara
dune in the hit disney plus show the
mandalorian
gina also happens to be a conservative
she sure isn't shy about it either
having been very vocal in 2020 on
masking mandates voter fraud black lives
matter and a particular note right now
that silencing an outrage for those with
different views
there was heat from the twitter mob
repeatedly often using the hashtag fire
gina carano
the hashtag swung back around last week
this time disney did just that
gina has since been fired by lucasfilm
which is owned by disney and has been
removed from their flagship show the
mandalorian
their statement reads quote for social
media posts denigrating people based on
their cultural and religious identities
are abhorrent and unacceptable
she was dropped by uta the talent agency
the raptor she joins us today to unpack
this unbelievable move
and hollywood's hypocrisy we discuss how
things escalated to this
if you should be canceling your disney
plus account which trended to the top of
twitter when the news of the firing
broke
and whether or not this is the story
that will finally break cancel culture's
grip
on american society
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show sunday special this show is
sponsored by expressvpn if you don't
like big tech and the government spying
on you
you should check out my friends at
expressvpn.com quick reminder
we'll be doing some bonus questions at
the end with gina the only way to get
access to that part of the conversation
is to become a member head on over to
dailywire.com become a member they'll
have access to all
of the full conversations with every one
of our awesome guests gina carrano
thanks so much for stopping by
thank you i'm not just stopping by i'm
like you're part of the thing
i'm coming in for the hugs so why don't
we start with you know the actual
topic of the day which is what exactly
happens you've said before that you felt
like you were
sort of on thin ice with disney plus and
lucasfilm
for a while what gave you that first
indicator first of all why don't we
start from the very beginning
how did you get cast in the show the
mandalorian to begin with so
i was sitting on my couch and i was
thinking you know i really have to take
this more seriously i have to take
acting more seriously i have to really
just
i have to give it my all um you know
because if i don't take myself seriously
as an actor then who else is going to
and as soon as i said that five minutes
later my man
my agent at the time uh called me and
said
john favreau wants to meet with you i
was like yes absolutely and and they
were like we don't know what it's about
and so
um we set up a meeting and john favreau
took me through
uh he's like you don't know why you're
here and i'm like no but here's a bottle
of wine
and i'm a big fan and he took me through
all the
concept art and he's like we're here to
cast you um
as a part in our new disney plus series
the mandalorian and uh and how quickly
was it apparent to you that
politics was going to be a problem uh
either in the production of the show or
on the set
or or in any way the interesting thing i
think about
this whole political thing in me is i've
never
i'm not i'm not like you
i've i've never been really interested
in politics and then um
as soon as i started seeing what was
happening um
i guess in 2020 i started looking up
like
well maybe the adults don't have it
under control
and maybe i'm an adult now and
maybe i have a responsibility to pay
attention and
i guess when we start when we first
started having
you know problems was um it had to have
been
on the pronoun usage i think was the
first
problem um maybe before that
well because you know i was really upset
about the shutdowns um
i know what it's like to be working and
then not not to work and then
you know i know the depression that like
comes with not working because my my job
has been on and off its entire life um
you know you got a job and then you sit
out a year and you got a job and you sit
out and
not having a job and not having purposes
it's devastating you know you go through
a depression it's not consistent
and i think i do good with consistency
can you take us through sort of the
controversy over the
transgender pronouns because that was
the first time you started really
trending on twitter for politics
i ended up putting beep bop boop in my
um twitter twitter bio and a hundred
percent
um it was a hundred percent to go to
the twitter mob that was telling you
what to do um and it had
zero to do with trying to go after the
the transgender
community because i would never do that
um i'm not
i'm just me personally i'm not trying to
target anybody or go out
after anybody and so as soon as i saw i
saw people started taking that wrong
you know i put right after that i was
like no beep bop boop was like
me just saying i literally said to my
friend i was like you know what
let's put something in my bio just to
show like i can put whatever i want
my bio just like they put like whatever
they want in their bio like trash panda
and all this stuff and like
you know um so i just put these noises
in my bio
and uh then there was this crazy
meltdown
it was just a big massive meltdown and
you know all the fear and all of the
stuff goes straight through your skin
and
you start like whoa what is happening
like i told you i didn't mean this
towards
this community and like you know you're
misunderstanding it um
and it was just a shock wave went
through my body so i was like oh this is
what this feels like this is
uncomfortable
so disney came to you and presumably
lucasfilm and asked you to put out some
sort of apology or
how did they how did they deal with that
i had a publicist at the time
and um they said you know
you know you have to put out you have to
you know you have to put out apology
this is messed up this is awful and i
was like um
okay uh i did say right after that tweet
i clarified for everybody
this was not directed towards the
transgender community in any way
and um and i've also been watching
celebrities apologize left and right
and it's very ingenuine and i said
can you just give me a moment because
i'm kind of feeling emotional right now
um and can i just do my own research you
know
um and so you know
they were like okay yeah um do your
research but you need to get on the
phone tomorrow with um
our lgbtq transgender section
and i was like i honestly i'm feeling
very emotional can you give me a second
and they said no
you need to do this now and so i did i
was like okay we have to do it now then
let's do it now
and so i walked i watched their
documentary and i got on the phone with
them
and they basically were you know just
two very
gentle people and they were like we're
so we're sorry
you know like you stepped in what they
they call a gold
a um a land mine and we can tell you
know you're not you're not
cured against us and um they actually
reported back to
disney and lucasfilm you know they
thought it would be a bad idea if they
canceled me
um you know or if they let this affect
anything because um
because you know i got on the phone with
him and i said
hey i gotta zoom with them and i
explained hey i just you know
i don't have any hate in my heart for
anyone
you know i just i stepped in the lineman
and uh and after that you've said before
that the
um the disney lucasfilm folks said that
you weren't
basically to do any press after that for
the mandalorian yeah so they
we went through this really long thing
where it was like
um back and forth back and forth they
wanted me to say this
i felt like it was ingenuine i wrote out
like this massive
um thing uh that said
i mean i have it and everything that i i
read through it and i was like
oh my gosh if i put out this statement
now it'd actually be
very enlightening to how i was feeling a
year ago
but um they they didn't want that
they they didn't want that i think you
know they thought you know i was already
taking too much
attention off of the mandalorian which i
it was not my intention you know because
i know how hard everybody works on it
uh because i i mean we got down to this
like statement within like two
words like almost like two words this
ridiculous thing and they were like
and they just said it was not apologetic
enough
and i was like i
i mean it was shocking like i want to
communicate
they wanted me to get and all these
lucasfilm employees
are railing me on their um websites
i mean one of them uh creative director
had to go fund me and in the
gofundme bio it was like uh this is
because our ignorant actress and
you know and like it was like you're you
so they wanted me get on the phone with
like 40 of their lgbtq
community not on the phone on zoom
and i felt like you're all these people
all your
your employees are slandering the hell
out of me right now
you think i want to get on a video where
they can then film it
you know and i felt very kind of
insecure about that so what i offered
them was
you know the restaurants at the time had
you know started opening back up and i
was like let me take you know
four or five of them out to dinner and
it'd be a you know a person a person
you can look me in my eyes i can look
you in your eyes and let's have a
genuine conversation
and i think it's also a bit abusive that
you want me to talk
to 40 people and hear 40 people
like i i just that
have been slandering like and maybe not
all of them have been sending
me but a lot of them probably had um
and it was just like wait
i don't feel like i really like deserved
this you know
i mean don't you guys see what's
happening online it's like all these
bots it's not even like faces it's not
real people it's just
and it feels like who i don't know who
these people are
children or just bots or whoever the
hell these people are
twitter rage mob yeah and and they're
they're awful and i actually asked the
lgbtq community
community leaders for the trans section
i was like why don't you guys address
that
um it might be healthier if you
addressed what's happening
the aggressive push and they didn't
really have an answer to that
so in a second i want to ask you about
uh you know how that
ended up playing out over the subsequent
few months because we're moving through
the sort of timeline here we'll get to
that in just
one second first there's never been a
more important time to protect your
internet activity than like
right this moment this is why i urge you
to get express
vpn everything you search for watch
click online it can be tracked by big
tech companies that can then match
your activity to your true identity
using your device's unique ip address
when i switch on expressvpn with my
computer or phone my ip address is
masked by a secure vpn server it makes
it harder for websites to identify me
which is exactly the point my data is my
business
the expressvpn app also encrypts my
network data to protect my sensitive
information
from being compromised plus you can use
expressvpn on up to five
devices simultaneously so multiple users
on your network can stay safe with a
single subscription
what i like most is how easy it is to
use it takes just one click to protect
all of your devices that's why they are
rated the number one vpn by cnet
and wired the reason that i use a vpn
again my data is my business i don't
want big tech
that kind of hates me to be monetizing
my data for their own gain
stop handing over your data to big tech
companies go to the vpn i trust
for online production visit
expressvpn.com to get three months free
on a one year package that's express
svpn.comben to get three extra months
for free go to expressvpn.com
ben right now to learn more alrighty so
let's talk about what happened next so
you had this run in with the higher ups
with regard to lgbtq
issues that was you know essentially
solved but at the same time they told
you not to go on the press junkets and
they didn't want you speaking to the
press
all right and then things it seems like
we're pretty quiet up until
about november and the hollywood
reporter later came out and they
reported that
disney plus and lucasfilm were thinking
about a spin-off for the mandalorian
where you would have a big role
they're going to present that to
investors and they decided that they
were essentially going to kill that
based on a couple of social media posts
that you put up
in november particularly one with
regards to voter fraud
uh and then one with regard to mask so
can you talk a little bit about that and
did they ever convey this to you
yeah so i mean they actually sent over
um
a a media trainer um which i felt like
okay
you know i'm down you know like come on
over
and she came in and she crossed her arms
she had her glasses on and she sat in
the corner and she's been very cold
and um she's in my house and i i asked
her i'm like do you think you can take
off your glasses so we can i can look
you in your eyes and so we can have a
conversation
because you know and she was like um
ready to hate me i think
and then you know we went and we then
sat down on the couch and we had a
lovely conversation
um and she said look you are you offered
a logical answer to an emotional
um response and that's not what they
respond to
um they they're only gonna they're only
going to
um it only helps if you offer an
emotional response to emotional response
and that's what she told me and i was
like well
i get that but why can't you off a lot
like why can't you offer a logical
answer
i mean that should be your right to um
you know my logical answer was you know
you guys kind of misinterpreted that and
there also
is this massive mob out there that's
just
bullying bullying people left and right
so i um
had a great conversation with her and
she left beaming and i
you know it was a great conversation it
was
not a problem um
and then i don't know i voted
[Laughter]
and that really is even according to the
sources that have talked to the
the hollywood media essentially what
happened is that that they were
still getting ready to feature you uh in
the disney shareholder meeting and all
of this and then uh decided that they
were not going to do
any of that and according to people
speaking to the hollywood reporter
they decided months in advance that they
were essentially looking for an excuse
to to get rid of you
have they conveyed any of that to you or
how did you find out that they had
decided not to
bring you on for for more at disney
plus and lucasville you know like boxers
head hunt
sometimes and they forget to go to the
body um i feel like disney
or lucasfilm or whoever
it is maybe just certain people in that
company
i feel like i've been being head hunted
um
for the last i don't know how many
months and you can feel it you know like
just a couple weeks ago lucasfilm asked
an artist
that they employ to erase my character
and put a different character in place
and you know he proudly announces this
on
um twitter and erases my character and
puts
you know another character in place and
all of the fans of
cara dune were just outraged you know
they're like why don't you just
add the character why did you have to
take off the characters
is there something wrong with gina
getting fired i've been
through so much and i've seen so much
now
clearly of like the bullying that's been
taking place
and i saw it before it's not like i mean
i'm not the only
one that's ever been bullied by this
company
and i know that i know that so deeply
that i could share a story and it would
turn things around in the media but
um i can't do that because
it would be selling out a friend that i
don't really
have the same views as but i'm not gonna
you know sell somebody to to take the
attention off me so
when if that person said something
about how hard i i went to bat for that
person
it would change things but
everybody's afraid of losing their job
so they
announced publicly that you're not
coming back after this
post that you put on social media and
we'll get to the contents of the post in
just a second
did they ever come to you and ask for an
apology did they ever come to you and
coordinate with you in any way or did
you just
essentially pick up a newspaper one day
and you read that you were no longer on
the show
i looked on the internet and you know
you check your twitter
and i'm trending and uh the fire
tuna corona hashtag worked so disney
never contacted you and asked for some
sort of back down or some sort of
explanation it was just
you're done and you find out essentially
the same way everybody else did well
yeah i mean i saw somebody from the
company
accidentally sent me a conversation
of that they were tracking the fire gina
chrono hashtag
on content that had nothing to do with
me it was actually like had
zero to do with me and then uh all of a
sudden
i i always get thrown in the mix like
okay so this is trending but
let's put her in there fire gina chrono
and um
they accidentally sent me an email which
was very enlightening so i knew
i knew they were paying attention i knew
they i know that there are some people
that went to bat for me
but i know that they didn't really win
out in the end
so let's talk about some of the
controversial social media posts because
i think it's good for you to be able to
explain exactly what we meant by this
yeah since people have deliberately
misinterpreted nearly everything yeah so
they they're there there are a few of
them uh there was the one right after
the election in which you
essentially said something that i think
virtually all conservatives believe
which is if you want to stop voter fraud
you need a voter id we need to tighten
up the voter procedures
for some reason people found this very
controversial right so
that one seemed fairly self-explanatory
to me yeah well it was my
this is not something i say with pride
but it was my first time voting
i have never voted before um and i know
i'm late to the game here but i just
i never really thought that it counted
and i really
i just politicians had never really
turned me on
and so i don't pay attention to things
that don't really turn me on
um i pay my my taxes and i pay a lot of
taxes and so i just
figured okay i'm doing my duty and i'm
just going to keep on fighting what i've
been trying to do is just get my career
going and keep on like
plugging through to where i can get you
know this bigger opportunity
the mail-in thing we got an extra
mail-in everybody i talked to got an
extra mail in ballot
and so i'm like okay so this is my first
time voting i'm gonna go in and i'm
gonna take this and i'm gonna like
i'm gonna do my part so that way i can
actually talk about it because
everybody says you know you can't talk
about it unless you vote and so i agreed
with them so i never talked about it
and then when i went in to i was ready
with my id
you know and i've got the and they just
asked my name
and they asked my address and i don't
even remember if there was a signature
required or not
and we have mass over our face and and
i'm ready with my id
to vote because that's what you know and
they were like no no you're fine just go
and i was like what you're not gonna
check this
like this is an important thing that i'm
trying to do right now i'm actually
like i want this to count and so that
was very
um confusing for me and so when
when the election you know happened and
everything was i
i was just like wait why like i feel
like there's a lot of outrage about this
and i don't i think this is confusing to
me as a newcomer into this and so
i just um i just thought well the
experience i went through is like there
was no id
there was no cameras it was on the beach
actually
it was like this little like hot on the
beach um and it was very um
you know i just i thought
that this could be a positive thing and
we should probably jump on this now if
this would ever be a future
you know you know because people in 2016
were talking about it
so it's not something that nobody was
ever talking about and so i was like
well let's get to the point
as a nation where we don't have to
really question this anymore
because i think that's a really
dangerous thing and i wanted this all to
end
and i wanted it to be like okay this is
your new president or this is the the
remaining president and
let's get past it and like join and go
and it didn't stop at you know
it didn't stop from there and i wanted
everything to stop from there and
so that's why i put out that post so as
i said that one was
to my eyes very uncontroversial then you
put up one that again was
fairly commonplace thought in
conservative circles you put up a meme
about taking the mask off your eyes you
can see what's really going on right
yeah and the way i interpreted that and
virtually every other conservative i
know was
all you were saying is that a lot of the
stuff that's been presented about covet
has been
exaggerated or not based on science or
based on politics and just bouncing
around it's just been bouncing back and
forth and um it's like
like uh masks are bad okay now masks are
good and now
you know it's just been like all over
the place so since the
i mean we're sitting there like wait
what is going on
you know just confusion um
so with that one though um i live in
california and
i i've seen the hypocrisy that's been
happening you know like
you know they're going to the french
laundry
and they don't have masks on and um
there's just been so much hypocrisy and
they have those like little edited
videos where you can see the
the democrat leaders just like
completely
the hypocrite like it was like we i just
always laughing like this is like
like hypocrisy 2020. and so um
so i just like put that out because i
thought that was like a good way to
convey that we need to start paying
attention to the hypocrisy so
for me it was just like
like open your eyes so those two again
were really
to my eyes for conservatives
particularly very uncontroversial then
we got to the one that uh that they
decided was
worthwhile getting rid of you over we'll
get to the social media post that had to
do with the holocaust in just one second
first let's talk about your sleep
quality
you may have noticed but sometimes i
look super tired because i have three
children and you may have noticed that
gina carano
she's been saying that she is short on
sleep well i have referred her to my
friends over at helix sleep because
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete
it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they've got soft
medium firm mattresses mattresses great
for cooling it down if you sleep hot
even got a helix plus mattress for plus
size folks it's been awesome getting
unboxing videos from so many of you who
also found the helix mattress of your
dreams so
if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to mattress comes
right to your doorship for free you
don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again helix is awesome but you
don't need to take my word for it helix
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine just go to helixsleep.com take
their two minute sleep quiz
they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they've got a 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for a
hundred nights where it's free
so what exactly do you have to lose the
answer of course is nothing
i have a helix sleep mattress my wife
and i did that two-minute sleep quiz
they made a mattress just for us and it
is indeed
fantastic right now helix is offering up
to 200 bucks off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com ben that's helix
sleep.com
ben for the special deal go check them
out let's talk about the social media
posts that brought the world down around
your ears this is a social media post in
which essentially you're making the
argument
that bad things the way you treat your
neighbor
can slide over into actual oppression of
your neighbor so there's a picture of a
woman
a jewish woman in the holocaust running
away from germans
and the caption essentially made the
argument that
nazis didn't start by killing people and
common germans didn't start by going
along with the holocaust
this all started by people dehumanizing
people who lived next door to them
and the reaction to this was that
somehow you were attempting to downplay
the holocaust or that you were comparing
republicans to
holocaust victims or something like that
i want to give you a chance to sort of
explain what you were thinking and what
you meant by that
i have been so inspired by like the
gentle spirit
of the jewish people going through that
time
and you know like you watch like the you
watch
i think i watched this older holocaust
survivor
um her court case and she was they
they found this old nazi man and
he was old and they like rolled him in
on a stretcher and like they you know
really played this up and she she
forgave him
she forgave him in court after putting
her
through what he did and she faced him
and i and i'm always so inspired
by these stories um and i always
wondered
like how how did that happen you know
what i mean
so when i posted that you know it wasn't
something that i felt like was
um controversial uh it was something
that i thought
well maybe all of us need to ask
ourselves how that happened
um because you know it's important
the post never said anything about
republicans or conservatives it doesn't
say anything about that in there it's it
was more about like
you know people tearing each other apart
and um
i thought it would be more of a thing
where you know bring people together
i was like oh this is like you know
bring people together but now after
hearing so much you know um
and i'm actually grown through the
experience of just knowing that
you know that's it's not fair to the
jewish community
to to you know just
throw this out here so much you know
like when you say the word nazi and when
you call someone a nazi
um and and you know you need to have a
little bit more
respect on it and so like i understand
that but um it was in a way in my
intention
you know i've got every single big
publication saying
she's comparing conservatives and
republicans to this
and um that's not really what i was
doing i was i was saying
we as a people because i still am very
refreshed to this political
you know spectrum
i mean i have love for everyone
i'm not a hateful person in fact
i go out of my way and i have gone out
of my way
my entire life not to be a hateful
person
i mean yeah i've fought in the ring and
i do have
hot blood um but it's usually hot blood
when it deals
with people being bullied and when i saw
people being bullied
that were silenced and scared to speak
i'm not i don't want to speak i want to
create art
you know um but i have a big problem
with
bullies and i have a big problem with
you know a
problem with power i have a huge problem
with abuse of power
well i mean it was it was fair and look
it was obvious to everybody and i i said
this to you when we first spoke
that it was obvious that this had
nothing to do with anti-semitism the
post obviously was not anti-semitic
you'd have to completely
twist the post backwards in order to get
to the idea that it was anti-semitic
since he was specifically decrying the
treatment of the treatment of jews who's
saying what happened to jews was evil
and this should never happen again and
that's why you should be careful about
how you treat your neighbor yeah
you know the jewish community is i think
properly
very sensitive about holocaust
comparisons and so uh you know i myself
on my show said that we have to be
careful about when we invoke the
holocaust but here's the thing disney
plus and lucasfilm
don't care how you invoke the holocaust
if you happen to be of a different
political persuasion
i pointed out on twitter right away as
soon as this broke that pedro pascal who
was
your co-star in the mandalorian in the
lead in that show that pedro pascal had
put out a holocaust
meme in 2018 in which he not only
got it the facts wrong he actually
posted a picture from not the american
border in 2018 and called it america
2018. he then compared the treatment of
migrant children in 2018 to victims of
the holocaust
in 1941 which is absolutely absurd on
every level
and of course disney plus and lucasfilm
had no problem with that whatsoever they
never said anything about it they never
responded to the comparison they never
said that it was
it was anti-jewish or anti-semitic to
make that comparison in any way
there was pretty obviously a double
standard of play here oh and there has
been
i mean they've been all over me and
they've been watching me like a hawk
and i'm watching you know other people
on the same
production you know and they can say
everything they want
and um and that's where i had a problem
i had a problem because i didn't want to
i wasn't going along with the narrative
um and and
you know what i adore pedro
i adore him i know he said and done
some hopeful things i don't think that
posting anybody's
number on social media is okay but i
know that you know he thinks a lot of
the stuff that i post
you know like but there's so much love
there still
you know um and we had agreement
after we realized we were a little bit
politically different
um we had an agreement that first and
foremost you're a human being
and you're my friend first
um and you know the two sides that you
know we're trying to
drag us apart because we're both
passionate and
you know and that's what's been really
crazy is like you see
these people over here being so
passionate you see people over here
being so passionate
and i i love that we're just about
passionate you know
um and we just we think we think a
little bit differently i think
through our different experiences so i i
know that
you know i know that we both have
misstepped
on our tweets you know we're not perfect
we're human beings
um but he's he's not a bad human being
he's a
he's a sweet person well i don't think
anybody thinks that any different i
think that the
the disparate treatment is the part that
was kind of shocking it was like one
one meme that invoked the holocaust to
say we shouldn't treat each other badly
is fireable and the other meme that
compares americans
uh americans you know trying to deal
with a problem of migrant children at
the border to the holocaust that that is
perfectly acceptable to disney plus and
lucasfilm
yeah and and then you saw the
back-filled sort of post-facto
explanation because it became very clear
to even a lot of members of sort of the
traditional liberal camp that what had
just happened to you was wrong you had
people like jonathan chade who's a
traditional liberal saying that this is
like mccarthyism
uh you had people who are traditionally
liberal saying that this is it's a
mistake
that you did censorship of a particular
point of view and that it was pretty
obvious that you were being
silenced and and canceled because you
were conservative and so at that point
you saw
the left swing into action and start
resurfacing old media posts and then
declaring those anti-semitic so
this is when they resurfaced a december
2020 post
that was a meme of essentially a bunch
of old men
no distinguishing anti-semitic features
which we'll discuss in a second
uh sitting over a monopoly board and the
meme said something like
and the monopoly board is sitting on the
backs of people who appear to be slaves
and the meme says something like if they
stand up then
if we all stand up the game is over yeah
and the implication
was made that this was an anti-semitic
meme and that you had known it was an
anti-semitic meme when it was posted so
i want to give you a chance to explain
what you were thinking when you posted
that meme because just for those who
don't know
the history of the meme itself it was a
meme that was posted by allies of jeremy
corbyn
essentially in great britain the
original meme had very semitic featured
people who's fairly obviously
anti-semitic and had you know characters
essentially from der sturmer the
nazi newspaper with the hook noses and
the edis and all this
this version that you posted didn't have
any of that so if you were not very
deeply into politics
it's very difficult to imagine that you
would even make that connection right
and so
so usually i like to post um i like to
post
think pieces and um what i found is
those those are what get me into trouble
the most
because that's when everybody starts
putting their opinion out there
it's like you know like the last poster
they're like oh look at look what she
said and i was like
um why don't you guys do your homework a
little better like it doesn't say
republican and conservative in that post
you know
um and so when people started saying
that that
um the game where if everybody would
just stand up
i thought that once again i thought that
was something that we could all join in
on
um and i had no idea obviously no idea
that
uh that the original one had been
um like i didn't know who those men were
but then
i saw what they were saying and then i
saw the post and i saw
the picture and they were two different
pictures and so i really didn't know i'm
like okay so
uh so do i take that down
like do i take that down when it's not
the same picture
um but the origins were because the idea
in itself is that if we all join
together
once again like my other one if we all
join together and stand up
if you really go through what i'm
posting
i post something because i want people
to think you know
and i want to hear what people have to
think and when people
people are calling me uh i've been
called so much like i'm
i'm called racist i've been called
transphobe
i've been called homophobe i've been
called now anti-semitic
and i'm like i don't take those
lightly like you're calling me my soul
the blood that runs through me you're
calling me that
and i i blocked so many people i'm like
you say that once
to me like you're done i don't want to
talk to you ever again i don't want to
see you on my feed
that was a lot of blocking i really
they're like oh she's got a blockchain
and i'm like no i'm doing it
like i'm pissed like you just insulted
me
and my my heart and my soul because i i
honestly do i've gotten
out of my way i and i know everybody on
the set of mandalorian
or any said i've been on my
my actions towards other human beings
have
spoken for themselves and i'm not a
perfect human being i have so much to
learn and i am gonna make mistakes
but i know everybody on that set and i
know that even the people that were
gunning for me like i know that
so many people have met me and worked
with me i know that's why
we might be seeing i go out of my way to
make sure i
am the one the onsets people come and
cry to
i'm the one that sticks up for someone
if they're being like hey this is enough
this person needs out of this
like they can't breathe um and i've
always been like that i've stuck up for
like minorities everywhere i've gotten
in fist fights
you know for i've been in actual fights
growing up in las vegas because i
cannot stand bullying and so um
yeah i think i you know
i just wanted people to think and i put
up something and people
were putting their own
they're putting their own perspective
and spin on it and then they put words
into my mouth that i never say
and then uh then they start you know
then it starts trending and all these
you know these big uh
newspapers and news articles and you're
like
do you know me like
get to know me like i told you know
they're they're transgender people i was
like let's
talk i'll look you in your eyes you're
not gonna
you're not gonna feel hate i promise you
so in a second i wanna ask you about the
decision to come work with us because
that's obviously something unique it's
never been done
uh in terms of uh somebody from
hollywood saying you know what
i can work over here and i'm just gonna
go do that so let's talk about that in
just one second first
we have to talk about life insurance so
here's the deal it's kind of hard to
find affordable life insurance people do
it by word of mouth not the best way to
do it
why not use the best tool available i'm
talking of course about policy genius
policy genius can help you check off two
big items from your to-do list with ease
you can compare life insurance rates
and you can say 50 or more in the
process that means more cash to put
toward the things you care about
whatever that may be
here's how it works first you head on
over to policygenius.com in minutes you
can work out how much coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price
policy genius will compare policies
starting as little as a buck a day you
might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam
once you apply the policy genius team
handles all the paperwork and the red
tape
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll take care of
everything for you soup to nuts there's
a reason the policy genius has a
five-star rating across over 1600
reviews
on trustpilot and google life insurance
that's the wrong thing to procrastinate
on because
if you wait too long it is absolutely
too late well if you are worried that
march is just around the corner and you
haven't gotten anything done take a deep
breath because policy genius is going to
help you make the most of february in
minutes head on over to policygenius.com
you could say 50
or more by comparing quotes and feel
good knowing that your loved ones would
be taken care of if god forbid anything
were to happen to you head on over to
policygenius.com right now to get
started that's policygenius.com
because when it comes to insurance it's
nice and very important to get it right
so in the middle of this obviously we
here at daily wire had been uh
foraying into the film industry we had
released our first film a little bit
earlier this year run height fight
our audience really loved it and when we
saw that you were trending
um my business partner jeremy and i
we thought the first thing we thought
was number one somebody should reach out
to gina because she's getting maligned
unfairly
um but number two we should reach out to
gina because this is an opportunity for
conservatives and people who think
differently to say to hollywood that
you're not
allowed to just cancel whomever you want
and uh
i mean i have to say that i was amazed
at how readily you were willing to jump
into
a project with derelicts like us
and willing to uh get involved in in one
of our projects uh because it is a
unique thing i mean in hollywood
typically the advice is keep your head
down make an apology maybe in three four
years you can sort of
wheedle your way back into the industry
but you didn't do any of that you were
basically ready to go from the moment i
gave you a call
i wanted to get your perspective on that
well because you know and my
newfound you know finding my political
uh voice you you're actually one of the
people i found
um as well as a bunch of you you're
actually you're your book was the first
one i read um
and it just really kind of it was so it
was so simple that it really kind of
explained like the events in such a
you know in such a good way to where it
is like it just felt logical it felt
logical
um and um
so i i i'm obviously like so excited
that you called i
i was you know i was prepared
to at any point get let go because i've
seen
this happen to so many people um
you know i've seen the looks on their
faces i've
seen the bullying that takes place
they've quit twitter
you know they've quit speaking they show
up to their red carpets and they're
depressed and they're sad and
there's hard hearts there and i was like
you're gonna you're you're coming for me
i know you are
it's not a they're making it very
obvious through their
employees that were coming from me and
so i was like well
well then i'm gonna go i'm gonna go down
swinging then
and i'm gonna stay true to myself and
i'm gonna let that speak
and um i think that's speaking so
when you called i you know i'm still
like
my body's still shaking you know
it's still devastating um
but the thought of
this happening to anybody else
especially like somebody who could not
handle this
the way i can no they don't get to do
that
they don't get to make people feel like
that and if i buckle them
then little girls and little boys who
are not getting any rep
like they're not getting a good fair
shake at growing up right now
if i buckle it's gonna make it okay for
these companies who have a history of
lying
to beeline and to do this to other
people and they've done it to other
people
and um
and i'm not going down without a fight
well we couldn't be more excited to be
working with you obviously and
and you can see that the the left is
creating a whole new cottage industry
for us because as they keep canceling
people for no good reason we are
perfectly happy to work with talented
people
of every stripe uh especially after the
left decides that
they are terrible bite into having
differing points of view
so i want to backtrack here a little bit
and talk about
how you even got into acting in the
first place because
you have the most unique acting story
that i know i mean
you started by hitting people in the
face uh so why don't we start
why don't we start with that like how
did when
when people think actress typically they
don't think a person who used to be an
mma fighter so first and when they think
mma fighter they don't tend to think
female generally so
you were the first big female mma star
in america
how did you get into mma that's that's
sort of the unique career path
oh well definitely not by my family's
approval
my my family actually did everything
they could to make sure that that
first uh sanctioned fight in las vegas
for a female women's
mma match did not happen and um
and so i was having to go through all
these extra tests and i found out like
my
who i love you know so much my papa don
who passed away
and my dad who's still around uh had
called the athletic commission and my
dad used to serve on the athletic
commission so
they were you know so i was going
through some extra tests because he did
not
want me to be a fighter they wanted me
to you know really go to school
and uh become a doctor a lawyer and
you know my family is the type of family
on both sides you know you're not
getting any of that you're not getting
anything for free
you earn your keep you're responsible
and you get out there and you work
and so um i was like okay that's what
i'm doing
and i don't like money being hung over
my head ever so
uh this is just something fighting was
just something that spoke to me
you know like it just made me want to
get in the gym it made me
um i was good at it i've been in fights
so many times in las vegas anyways never
that i started
um i was always like defending people
it's like
i am able to walk away from a fight but
when i realize that has something to do
with somebody else
and i have like there's this hot blood
that goes through me
and then and then things happen
um but so yeah i just started fighting
and um i loved it it's like
all of the bad things i was doing and
all the i've had friends shot in the
head and
left in the desert i have been stabbed
and head and left in the desert in las
vegas um
you know overdoses and the whole story
of like this tragic thing and i didn't
i was like okay why don't you just try
try to give life a chance
and i started training and fighting and
it just became
my new addiction and from the moment i
started doing it everybody was
pointing a camera at me i'm actually
extremely shy
i'm actually like it's hard for me you
know performing or talking and having
things
but um i think i'm getting a little bit
better at it
so i will admit although you probably
couldn't tell
being that i am such an adonis like
figure i mean it's just an
amazing greek god of masculine power
i'm not a person who's done a lot of
fighting as you you maybe you might have
guessed that i don't know
but yeah no most people picked up on
that in any case
what is it like to be a professional
fighter what is it like that's always
been fascinating to me because of
somebody who
uh you know went to jewish day school
and basically fights consisted
of people you know randomly wailing on
each other without any sort of real form
or
let's put this way no one from my jewish
day school ended up as a professional
fighter
so what is it like being a professional
fighter what's it like walking into a
ring and knowing that you have to beat
the hell out of somebody else in order
to uh in order to win
well i think it starts in walking into a
gym and
the most beautiful thing about walking
into a mixed martial arts gym
is it doesn't matter what color you are
what religion you are if you're a cop or
if you're not
it doesn't matter who you are you get
into that gym and you start training
together and
it's the full it's everybody in that gym
and you know you get humbled every
single day
and then you learn how to like be a part
of a team and then you start
taking care of each other and then you
start seeing i mean you see
all the weaknesses of like you know the
ego flare-ups and then like you know
wait okay so you know you really have to
balance your ego
in an mma gym because if your ego gets
ahead of you like that's a weakness
um so like i love that i love genuine
and i love real
human beings and so that was like a
place of like
everybody in this you know everybody
belongs here and the fighting part that
was that was hard
but uh there's nothing like facing a
fear
um you know and it's very intimate it's
like
i'm attracted to intimacy as well
so i when you look across um
a ring and you're looking at that
person's eyes you know
this is all about to get very real and
it's only going to be
me and you and there's going to be a
genuine interaction
and i crave those kinds of things that
was addicting to me
did you have to learn to take a punch i
mean how does that work as somebody who
has full-time security i will never have
to deal with this
i don't know i just uh since i had been
in fights growing up
i uh i have an incredible
i have an incredible chin
i'm like like my nose i i think you know
it's
it just like it takes uh if i bleed you
know
i'm hurting because i'm not a bleeder
and my chin is just good so i
i have this special little talent that i
have
um i hit pretty hard
and uh like i've been comp
like i've been very complimented on how
hard i can hit
um and so uh
i just i became addicted to it and i
still have a little bit of an
addiction to it i still do mma in in
your
my whole garage is like my whole life i
have so many friends that are fighters
and
you know they're so real like you point
a camera at them and it's like
effortless
because they they don't they haven't
sold themselves
you know but they haven't sold
themselves
they they own themselves and they know
that they're gonna take themselves into
battle
against another person and um
and i like that as well like being a
part of hollywood you know people are
stabbing you in the back left and right
and people are willing to cut your
throat just to get another job and
you're like whoa
like i've never been that way i'm never
gonna
actually i've when i did american
gladiators
um we were doing the jousting thing and
i took down this girl
the bigger girl i took her down um
and it was her dream to be american
gladiator right like she wanted to be an
american gladiator and like i took her
down in like two shots and like you know
then she ran to the bathroom and started
crying and
i realized at the moment i was like oh
my i am not going to take this job away
from her like we're doing tryouts right
now and i just knocked her off of that
and i'm not really super passionate
about being like putting spandex anyway
so i was like
you know and so like i kind of just like
exited like the tryouts and i jumped in
my impala
and i drove driving back to vegas from
la
and the producers were calling me up and
they always yeah i keep in touch with
them sometimes and
they're like aren't you glad we made you
do that but like and i
i got on the i finally picked up and the
producer was like
he's like gina please come back and i
was like
no no man like i'm not about to take
that job away from that woman she
wants to be there i don't care if i'm
there i'm not going to cut
and they're like what helga no we love
her
and i was like okay but i still don't
really want to do it
and it took them four phone calls in
order to
for me to like you know i showed up the
day of filming
and they hadn't even got an outfit for
me and i showed up and like they ended
up using me for almost everything
like physical like the wrestling and the
pyramid and everything
because um you know just because you got
muscles doesn't mean you'd be so
athletic so
i was it was such a fun job and i'm glad
i did it so what is your
sort of daily workout regimen like now
um
well for the last week it was a little
bit of crying in bed
i mean i do want people to know that you
know
this this has not been easy
and i think you know i have i'm a human
being i have so much
to learn and grow and i am um
i am deeply understanding um it's like
the
curtains got bold and i'm seeing so much
and um so that's been a very large
realization
so i do think when this does happen to
people it's like
you know being canceled might become
trendy one day
um but don't think that when it happens
to you it's gonna be easy
because it's not it's going to be maybe
possibly one of the hardest things
that you've ever been through but i
think you know
each day that goes by you kind of stand
up and you
find your legs again and you stop
feeling sorry for yourself
and you you show up you show up to an
awesome
opportunity with people who
want you to sit at their table you know
um
i think it was nina simone that said
something along the lines of you need to
understand
when love is no longer being served at
the table
so you need to understand when to leave
and
okay i'm not going to shove my self down
anybody's throats we disagreed
it didn't go well 2020 was a very
emotional year for a lot of people
um okay i'll get up and find another
table
and hopefully invite more people to that
because i'm about love
and real true diversity what was it like
to move from mma into hollywood how did
that transition actually happen
so moving from la to hollywood i had
just lost the biggest fight of my life
which that was another time where i was
kind of feeling like
staying in bedford there's some
controversy around that fight now with
regard to the person who you were
fighting
oh cyborg um are you talking about
steroids yes
yeah um you know it's not my job to go
point in the fingers that are
so i you know i take the loss i'll take
it on the chin
i'll take the loss because what happened
to me the next week
was um kind of similar to the situation
like
you showed up when i needed somebody
when i was in
just hurt mode and when i was in hurt
mode
uh steven soderbergh showed up i didn't
know that was at the time
and he said you know they like oh you
know
stephen sodeberg wants to have a
conversation with you and i'm like who's
that
and then um we had a beautiful
conversation and he said okay well this
is going to happen
really quick or not at all and it
happened and then i've had then i found
a new
something tricky and new because i being
an athlete it's like you always have to
be yourself out in front of everybody
um and i've always been really attracted
to art because i think art really does
change the world you know
i love art i love putting out things
where it's like think about it
and everybody sees it differently that's
my favorite everybody feels it
differently and everybody finds
different
movies and shows and art and they find
them at different points in their life
and it's their expression of who
they are i love that and so here's my
opportunity because i cannot paint
and you know like so i found an art that
i dove into
and um yeah that
that's not been easy sometimes i think
god it was a little bit easier getting
punched in the face
at least you didn't see the knife coming
through your back
so in just a second i want to ask you
about the response that you've gotten to
the move
to daily wire and then what we're doing
and i want to tell you about the
response that we've got which has been
overwhelming first
let's talk about your employment
situation how do you get better
employees at your company
it can be really tough to find the best
candidates finding great candidates for
a job and hiring them it can be like
trying to find a needle in a haystack i
mean you can post your job to some job
board and then all you can do is hope
the right person comes along
but you really shouldn't instead you
should try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
ben guest because i have a guest zip
recruiter does the work for you
when you post a job on zip recruiter it
gets sent out to over 100 top job sites
with just one click then
zip recruiters matching technology finds
people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply
you're going to get qualified candidates
fast so while other services may
overwhelm you with applications to sift
through
zip recruiter finds you what you are
looking for that needle in the haystack
in fact
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within
the very first day it's really important
for companies right now to find the best
people applying for their jobs and by
the way if you're looking for a job
really important to find the best job
this is why you should head on over to
zip recruiter right now you can try zip
recruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com ben guest that is
ziprecruiter.com
because i have a guest zip recruiters
dot com slash ben guest just go to
ziprecruiter.comrecruiter it's the
smartest way to hire
let's talk about the reaction that
you've gotten on a personal level to the
announcement that you're going to come
make a movie
with us i can tell you that the reaction
on our end has been spectacular i mean
our
our viewers our listeners they love it
it's the single biggest thing we've ever
done as a company
uh people are are excited about it
people are subscribing people are pumped
about it and they understand that it is
a challenge
to the hollywood system not just because
we're making entertainment which they're
excited about
but because it really is a challenge to
the monopoly that hollywood has where
they get to decide who can work and who
cannot
and people are excited to be part of the
fight what's the response that you've
been getting
the response has been um basically
that's that's why i think i've been
in tears you know like this
overwhelming
people sending me i mean
when i am at like my lowest people are
like pulling me
up in droves and um
you know so many people are like um
they're contacting me they're like you
know gina
you're so brave i'm still so afraid
and i just think oh man
you should be more afraid that you're
being made
to feel afraid for what you think that's
what should
make you feel afraid because
we got i i got two new nieces and one on
the way
i don't have any children but that sets
in for me
you know i gotta make this place a
better place
um for these kids so many people
are contacting me
in these people's companies
so it's not necessarily by the way it's
not necessarily like
who you think it is it's people that
you might not think it is and you know
so don't start going for everybody that
might have been supported for me because
you'd be surprised how many people
are into this the fans and people
have rallied behind me and spoken with
their voice and made their voice heard
and i am i'm i feel so stripped in a way
of like
like i feel so down but at the same time
i have this
the biggest fire inside of me because i
feel
um the need for this
for people they're they're drinking it
like it's water
they needed somebody to do this they
need somebody they need somewhere else
to go
they're all afraid and um
just like you know i've been saying like
you know it's going to suck
but you defend one person you see how
they treat you you understand what
people have been going through that are
getting canceled especially people you
know
that maybe probably didn't deserve it
you know um you'll experience it for
yourself
and then you'll be a better person for
it because
i have to get to the end of my life as
we all do
and um i have to meet my maker um and so
when i get there like now that's more
like i want to be able when i show up
there
i can be proud of that so it's you know
that's my that's my life gold now just
and the movement's been insane because
i'm busier than ever people are
i can't even keep up with it because i
lost you know half my team
i can't even keep up with the incoming i
mean there's so much and i'm trying to
like read all the scripts but like uh
it's so exciting i mean i said it
earlier this year that like i i want to
do my own
you know project um i have dreams i want
to push it here i want to produce on it
you know
and i was really excited about that i
just didn't think it was going to come
like this
like i didn't think it was going to like
really like i knew it could be a
possibility but
when you think something's a possibility
and then it happens you're like
wow like it's like that and it's scary
it did take courage
for you to do that as i said before like
the typical hollywood move and i know
so many people in hollywood right i was
living in l.a until five minutes ago
i wrote an entire book on television uh
i have a lot of friends who work in
hollywood at the highest levels and when
i get together with them we have a rule
which is that we used to get together at
the coffee bean on the corner of
coldwater
and ventura boulevard and we wore
baseball caps and we'd go early on a
sunday morning because the idea was that
if we were ever spotted publicly
together then these people would be
canceled and they knew this
and isn't that insane like somebody new
to the
you know political world i mean i'm
sitting there thinking like you know i'm
like
listening to a lot of you guys and like
listen and i'm like you guys were making
the most sense to me that was all
like you guys seemed intelligent
well-spoken
you're speaking some truth you're
calling out like hard truths
and um that's why i was like okay you
know like you know that's why
i kind of have found myself in on this
side you know i guess
and um but like i would go down and uh
you know
like to a barbecue on the beach in
california and
um all these people are like hey
we agree with you um it's messed up
isn't it
and i'm like this is your house
why are you whispering that that is
certainly the attitude in hollywood
i mean it's it is it is overwhelming in
hollywood and the number of people who
are in
positions of real power in hollywood who
agree with us
on politics is not insignificant and
there are a significant number of people
in power but they also understand
that their career is on the line and
they're deeply afraid that their number
is going to get
pulled next and you see it week in and
week out i mean the same week that they
cancelled you they went after chris
harrison on the bachelor for the great
sin
of suggesting that a female contestant
ought to be given grace
after she went to an old south costume
party three years ago and he ended up
being suspended
he made an apology which you should
never do never apologized to the mob and
he ended up being suspended from the
show essentially for the rest of the
season he may never get his job
back this is the thing that people in
hollywood are deeply afraid of but
unlike those people you actually had the
courage to say
okay well then i'm just you don't want
me here fine i'll just go do my own
thing
yeah and that does take a certain amount
of stones
frankly i just uh i just
i don't know that's the way i've lived
my life and
that i wasn't gonna stop now it's not
that i didn't love the job
you know i just i felt that what was
happening
the silencing that was happening the
fear of having open conversations that
was happening
i felt like that was insanely wrong and
um
and i don't want people to be afraid it
hurts me i don't want to speak i don't
want to talk about it but like
i i don't want people to be afraid the
i think one thing that folks don't
understand outside of hollywood is how
many people work on a set
so they think that when it comes to a
hollywood set it's basically the actors
and like one camera guy
and that is not correct i mean even in
shooting this show we have you know a
dozen people in the room
just to shoot this show to shoot an
actual full-fledged tv show with
multiple cameras and all this you're
talking hundreds of people
on the crew yeah and the crew and mirror
always the best well
that's the point that i was gonna make
is that you know when they when they
cancel you you're a top-of-the-line
person and
you're you have a lot of name cache
you're very famous you're very popular
and so for us to make a move with you uh
made a lot of sense but our goal here is
to build something that's big enough
where if somebody who's below the line
gets canceled
that person has a place to go because
those are the people who first of all
are disproportionately conservative a
huge number of people who are the actual
people who make things go on a set yeah
are conservative yeah and those are the
people who also have the most to lose in
a way
because those are the people who if they
get canceled in hollywood it's not like
they can
necessarily walk across the street to a
nascent startup and make that happen
hopefully we can build something where
those people don't have to live in fear
that one day they might be caught
listening to the wrong podcast and get
booted off the set they're just the grip
yeah and i think if anything uh
i think there's a fire right now in
people's hearts there's they're speaking
the people
are speaking they're speaking right now
out there they
and i think honestly hollywood's shook
i think they're shook i think they see
the hypocrisy
i see i think they see the double
standard
and uh i read this somewhere it's like
don't make don't try to ruin my life
with
lies when your life can be ruined with
the truth
and i uh you got
billion dollar companies raining down on
me
from every different place
and do i really even need to say
anything like
you're showing it you're showing what
you do to people
you're showing you don't give them a
voice you're showing you're not going to
listen
you're not going to see a person past
you know what you've
read in a very skewed article
you're showing what bullies you are
against one voice here
one i'm not petrifying to these billion
dollar companies
well good i hope i am and i hope
and i hope everybody else becomes that i
mean this is what they're afraid of
they're afraid of one voice imagine
well it's it is again amazing that the
same company that has decided that you
are
too much to work with uh is thanking
the government of china in a prominence
where they are getting genocide against
weaker muslims
uh at the end of mulan so uh clearly
they have uh
the double standard is extraordinarily
strong uh with regard to with regard to
these
exact companies so i want to ask you
gina carano a few more questions
starting with what kind of movie do you
want to make here i mean because we're
actually going to have to make a movie
at some point
but if you'd like to hear gina carano's
answers you have to be a daily wire
member
go to dailywire.com click subscribe use
promo code gina for 25
off you can hear the rest of our
conversation over there
um gina carano can't wait to get started
working with you everybody make sure to
subscribe over at dailywear.com stay
tuned for updates on our brand new film
with gina it's only just the beginning
of our fight against the leftist
narrative in hollywood we need your help
to take back our culture and cancel the
counselors gina thanks so much for
joining the show and thanks for working
with us oh my gosh
thanks for you know thank you so much
for that
phone call i mean i needed it thank you
thank you so much i needed
[Music]
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pavel wydowsky
associate producer nick sheehan our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl audio is mixed
by mike coromina hair and makeup is by
fabiola cristina
title graphics are by cynthia angulo the
ben shapiro show sunday special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021